cost support options.
.
>> I ASKED YOU A SIMPLE QUESTION
AND I WOULD LIKE FOR YOU TO
ANSWER SIMPLY.
DOES IT MAKE SENSE FOR THE
LEADERS OF THE FREE WORLD TO GO
AND TO TALK AND SEE WHAT’S GOING
ON AT THE BORDER?
>> I AM THE SECRETARY OF
HOMELAND SECURITY AND IT IS MY
RESPONSIBILITY TO MANAGE THE
BORDER AT THE DIRECTION OF THE
PRESIDENT AND THE VICE
PRESIDENT.
AND I HAVE VISITED THE BORDER ON
MULTIPLE OCCASIONS.
THE VICE PRESIDENT SERVED AS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF A BORDER
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND SHE IS
QUITE FAMILIAR WITH THE
SITUATION ON THE BORDER.
>> BUT SHE IS LAUGHING.
WILL: HEATED EXCHANGE BETWEEN
RALPH NORMAN AND SECRETARY
MAYORKAS OVER THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HANDLING OF THE
BORDER CRISIS.
PETE: THIS AS 56 REPUBLICANS
URGE THE PRESIDENT TO REMOVE
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS FROM HER
ROFL LEADING THE CONGRATULATION
DRIVERS.
RACHEL: CONGRESSMAN JOINS US
NOW.
>> GLAD TO BE HERE, RACHEL.
RACHEL: YOU CALLED FOR HER
RE345068.
DO YOU THINK IT’S GOING TO
HAPPEN?
IT SOUNDS LIKE SHE MIGHT WANT TO
GIVE UP THIS ROLE ANYWAY.
SHE DOESN’T SEEM TO LIKE IT?
>> THEY ARE RUNNING OUT OF
PEOPLE, RACHEL.
IF ALL SHE CAN DO IS LAUGH WHICH
IS WHAT SHE HAS DONE BY GOING TO
THE BORDER THEN SHE SHOULD BE
REMOVED NOW.
I DON’T KNOW WHO THEY WOULD HAVE
IN HER PLACE.
THIS ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO
BAFFLE ME ON THE PEOPLE IN
CHARGE, INCLUDING MAYORKAS AND
PARTICULARLY THE VICE PRESIDENT.
YOU KNOW, FOR HER TO SAY IN
GUATEMALA THAT NOT TO COME I
MEAN, WHO IS SHE, MOSES ON THE
MOUNTAIN TOP SAYING NOT COME AND
THINK THAT WE ARE GOING -- THAT
IT HAS ANY MEANING OR MERIT?
IT DOESN’T.
PETE: THAT’S THE WHOLE POINT OF
GOING TO THE BORDER,
CONGRESSMAN.
YOU CAN SAY THE BORDER IS
CLOSED.
IF YOU ARE DOWN THERE AND SEE
THAT IT ISN’T, IT MIGHT CHANGE
YOUR POLICY PRESCRIPTION.
ARE YOU SATISFIED THAT EVEN IF
IT VISIT FROM HER WOULD DO THAT
OR IDEOLOGICALLY ARE THEY TOO
INVESTED IN THEIR OWN NARRATIVE
AT THIS POINT?
>> WELL, ACTIONS SPEAK LOUDER
THAN THEIR WORDS.
NO, THEY ARE NOT GOING TO DO
ANYTHING.
I MEAN, THAT’S WHY THEY ARE
TAKING THE POSITIONS THAT
THEY’RE.
MY FIRST QUESTION TO MAYORKAS
HAVE YOU EVER HAD A MEDICAL
PHYSICAL AND HIS RESPONSE WAS HE
WAS INSULTED.
I SAID I’M NOT ASKING ABOUT WHAT
THEY FOUND.
I’M SAYING HAVE YOU HAD A
PHYSICAL?
A PHYSICAL YOU LITERALLY GO INTO
THE OFFICE AND ASK QUESTIONS AND
MEET THEM FACE TO FACE.
AND HE AND -- AND I SAID WHAT’S
THE DIFFERENCE WITH GOING TO THE
BORDER, PARTICULARLY WHEN IT
EFFECTS AMERICA IN A WAY IT’S
AFFECTING IT.
AND, YOU KNOW, HIS WORDS WERE
STUDY WALK THE WALK.
I SAW THE STEEL ON THE GROUND
THE POSTS UP YOU ARE NOT
BUILDING IT WELL, WE ARE
INVESTING IN TECHNOLOGY.
REALLY?
HOW GOOD IS TECHNOLOGY GOING TO
BE WHEN YOU HAVE 1.5 MILLION
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT ALREADY IN
AMERICA?
TECHNOLOGY GOING TO CHASE THEM
DOWN?
NO.
WE HAVE A SAYING IN THE SOUTH
DON’T SPIT IN MY FACE AND TELL
ME IT’S RAINING.
AND THAT’S WHAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO DO
AND WE’RE GOING TO CALL THEM OUT
ON IT.
WILL: YOU KNOW, CONGRESSMAN IF I
NEGLECTED TO GET MY PHYSICAL
THERE WOULD BE A REASON IF I
WOULDN’T GO TO THE DOCTOR.
I BELIEVE THERE IS NOTHING WRONG
WITH MYSELF DON’T BELIEVE THE
DOCTORS OR MAYBE I’M JUST LAZY
THAT I WOULDN’T GO GET THE
PHYSICAL.
IN YOUR SPHIMTION IT’S CLEAR A
SOBER MINDED PERSON WOULD LOOK
AT THIS AND SAY IT’S CLEAR THEY
ARE NOT ADDRESSING THE BORDER
CRISIS IN RESPONSIBLE FASHION.
THAT LEADS TO THE QUESTION OF
WHY.
WHY AREN’T THEY WILL TO GET THE
PHYSICAL AND BORDER CRISIS AT
ITS CAUSE?
>> WELL, THEY DON’T WANT THE
MEDIA ATTENTION.
THEY THINK AMERICANS WILL GIVE
THEM A PASS ON IT.
WHEN WE WENT, WE -- THEY
WOULDN’T ALLOW US TO TAKE
PICTURES.
THEY HAD BUSS THAT WERE
LITERALLY HAULING THE CHILDREN
OUT TO GOD KNOWS WHERE SO WE
COULDN’T SEE THE CAGES THEY WERE
IN.
AND IT’S REALLY AN INSULT WHAT
THEY ARE DOING.
AND ONCE THEY ARE IN THE
COUNTRY, THAT’S IT.
AND THEIR END GAME IS TO GET
REGISTERED TO VOTE AND DRIVER’S
LICENSE AND PUT THEM ON THE
PUBLIC DOLE AND HAVE VOTERS.
THAT’S THE ONLY THING THAT YOU
CAN REALLY ASSUME THEY ARE
DOING.
BECAUSE IT MEANS VOTES TO THEM.
AND THEY THINK THAT’S A -- PUT
THEM IN A PERMANENT POSITION TO
WIN ELECTIONS.
RACHEL: I THINK YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
WHEN YOU GO TO THE QUESTION OF
WHY.
I THINK YOU HAVE HIT THE NAIL ON
THE HEAD.
THAT’S EXACTLY WHY THEY ARE
DOING IT AND EXACTLY WHY THEY
WON’T CHANGE THEIR POLICY
WHETHER SHE GOES THERE OR NOT.
LAST WEEK, I BELIEVE, ON LAURA
INGRAHAM’S SHOW RAYMOND AROAR
ROW HAD AN INCIDENT REPORT ON
THE BORDER WHERE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND MAYORS AT THE BORDER WERE
SAYING WE FEEL LIKE WE ARE
HELPING THE CARTELS.
SO THEY ARE BRINGING THE PEOPLE
ACROSS AND WE JUST TAKE THEM AND
DO THE NEXT PART OF THE JOB
WHICH IS JUST MOVING THEM ON TO,
YOU KNOW, AS YOU SAID ALL ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
I MEAN, WE ARE ACTUALLY DOING --
WE ARE FORCING OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO DO THE WORK OF
THE CARTELS.
THIS IS LIKE INSANITY.
>> IT IS INSANITY, RACHEL.
IF YOU TALK TO THE BORDER PATROL
AGENTS.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THEY’RE DOING?
THEY’RE CHANGING DIAPERS.
THEY ARE NOT DOING WHAT THEY
WERE TRAINED TO DO.
THAT’S WHY AT LEAST THEY VISIT.
EVEN IF YOU ARE NOT GOING TO DO
ANYTHING WOULD HIGHLIGHT THE
PROBLEMS.
AND MAYBE, I DOUBT IT, I DOUBT
IT BUT MAYBE IT WOULD GIVE THEM
SOME EMPHASIS TO STOP THE
INSANITY.
ONCE THEY ARE IN THE COUNTRY,
THEY ARE IN THE COUNTRY, WE ARE
NOT GETTING TO GET THEM OUT.
AND THEY WILL BE ON THE SCHOOL
SYSTEMS HOSPITALS YOU NAME IT
PUBLIC.
WE CAN’T PUT UP WITH THAT OR TRY
TO DO WHAT WE CAN TO HIGHLIGHT